الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب كان
ولا يزال محبا للاضواء اثناء فتره حكمه
وما بعدها سعيه وراء الاثاره دفعه
الاستغلال موضوع محاكمته بقضايا جنائيه
باعلان امنيته المثول امام المحكمه مكمله
بمحكمه من هات امنيه تلك لكن ذكاء
الاصطناعي كان اسرع استجابه مع مجتاح
مواقع الاخبار ومواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
حول قضيه اعتقال ترامب تنقل رواد مواقع
التواصل صورا جرى تصميمها بواسطه الذكاء
الاصطناعي تظهر عمليه اعتقال المنافس
المحتمل للرئيس الحالي جو بايدن في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه رغم عدم وجود
اعتراف صريح ينص على ان الصوره المفبركه
لاعتقال ترامب جرى انشاؤها بواسطه الذكاء
الاصطناعي
لكن عده مؤشرات تضمنتها الصور اكدت عدم
مصداقيتها بدءا من الموقع الذي عمل على
تصميم تلك الصور وهو معمل مجاني المتخصص
بابحاث برامج الذكاء الاصطناعي لكنه يعاني
من عيوب تقنيه بسيطه في تصاميمه غير انها
حاسمه ان تمت بالفعل ملاحظتها على سبيل
المثال ترامب غير المكتمله مجرد تشويق
الذي تخيلته الصور كافل لتخيل المشهد
الواقعي وما قد ينجم عن حادثه بهذه
الضخامه سابقه باعتقال رئيس سابق للولايات
المتحده
صور نقله اللغط الذي قد يصاحب عمليه
اعتقال ترعب سقوط للرئيس مقاومه ورد فعل
كبير على هذه الانبا فبمجرد نشر الصور تمت
اعاده مشاركتها على مواقع التواصل اكثر من
خمسه ملايين مره لحظه مزيفه لكنها قادره
على قلب المعادله وخلق واقع وهمي يسهل
نشره دون معايير منظمه هذا ما حضر منه
مرارا صانع السياسه من اساءه الاستخدام
المحتمله للوسائل الاصطناعيه بنشر معلومات
مضلله وبث الفتنه وارباك المشهد السياسي